this is the bare minimum method
to getting all A stars at A level.
from now to February,
don't write any notes.
it's just really long.
instead of notes,
make flashcards for every topic
or even better
go online and use somebody else's flashcards.
next, in about mid January,
start the exam questions
for each topic.
you wanna go for exam questions for every single topic
but do not use the actual mock papers
because you wanna save these
for closer towards your exam
around about March
is when you should be doing full mock papers
and even better
start taking a look at the examiner's Report
about this time as well.
the examiner's Report is a document
written every year by examiners.
it basically just tells you the most common mistakes
made for every single question within that paper.
probably the best resource you can use in your revision
and that's literally all there is to it.
a simple bare minimum strategy
that will get you
the greater you need